jennifer aniston completely transforms  for her latest role it's a good thing  the friends alam traded in her usual red  carpet glam for a much more from piure  look on the set of her new movie  dumpling and don't throw your jaw it  almost doesn't feel like work the  actress who plays a mom in the film  arrived to set looking happy and healthy  Jen nailed the parental look sporting a  yellow blouse tucked in a pencil skirt  and paired with a chunky belt  she looked nearly unrecognizable with a  half-up half-down hairdo and bass so I  was just really just being loyal to the  script into the to the woman that I was  portraying 48 year old Jen is set to  play Willow Dean Dixon's mother Rosie in  the flick her teenage daughter enters a  beauty pageant to win over boys and get  back at her bullies and we think jen has  her pageant mom looked down perfect I  know  [Music]